[Music]
live from Los Angeles The Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
presents Oscar the 66th annual Academy
Awards a welcome addition to the Oscar
cast and a presenter this evening
Christian Slater this dedicated actress
will be a presenter this evening madin
Stow new film star a nominee for
original song Janet Jackson
last year's winner for best actress and
a double nominee tonight Emma Thompson
last year's winner for best supporting
actor Jean Hackman heavy favorite for
Oscar recognition Steven Spielberg
accompanied by his wife actress Kate
Capshaw Oscar winner for my left foot
nominated again tonight Daniel D
Lewis